um
robert you're talking about the mindset
of like most guys earlier and sarah sent
me a video
um about uh i came out with the title
was something around um debt being dumb
you know essentially oh by the way
robert you were right you know you were
talking about being a big fat beta the
last time we were talking yeah and that
video that i watched and and it had ken
and tom in it as well it looked like it
was about 20 years old you look like a
totally different guy back then
yeah yeah like much like a lot more you
know in the face than ahead you've lost
a lot of that weight so good for you but
um
in those videos you were you were
talking about the um concept about how
people struggle with the idea of like
good debt versus bad debt right and a
lot of them have you know limiting
beliefs i don't know if you know this
but i built one of canada's most
successful debt negotiation companies i
started in 2003. uh i pulled out of it a
few years ago my brother runs it now for
the most part so i'm i'm very very
familiar with the mindset that most
people have when they consume uh
unsecured debt and create credit card
debt and
you know what what sort of problems that
creates in their lives can you talk a
little bit more about the mindset you
know between you know those like
limiting limiting beliefs around
debt all debt being bad versus how you
actually make money with that
yeah i think i think you called it a uh
scam i think it was scam number seven
was it
it's uh it really is a mindset it's a i
call it culture there's a guy
gladwell canadian
and and he says
what keeps a person where they're at is
their culture for example
i'm japanese but my culture is american
and so a poor person is a person of a
culture well
eat drink and be married for tomorrow we
die so they spend
so they lack the discipline
the other part of the the hardest thing
when i talk to people i mean i've got to
do fights
you know i i like it like an obnoxious
character i am i said well i just don't
want to pay taxes
and i tell you there are some of these
people who get off they say that's
criminal you're a criminal
you know they think not they think they
think paying taxes is patriotic
and i point out to them if you
understood macroeconomics
that in 1773
america had a party it was called the
boston tea party
it was it was a revolt against paying
taxes so america was formed as a
tax-free nation
and but it's been the kool-aid has been
drunk uh
sold off to people that you have to pay
taxes
and the person who says taxes are
important are marxists
you know i mean karl marx in his book
capitalist communist manifesto said
you want to kill the middle classes
grind them with taxes
so they're inculcated via the education
system that if you pay taxes you're
patriotic
when on the b and the i side it's
completely opposite you know i always
say there's three sides to every coin
heads tails at the edge of the coin
on the b on the i side of the coin i
don't want to pay tax i'm a capitalist
i'm also a patriot
so what tom says is accurate
tax laws
are incentives to do what the government
wants done
so just
just recently i'll make it even worse
rich yeah go ahead
uh but this colbert thing coming up oh
we're forced to buy jets right tom
that's right
we kenny i bought their sexy and what
did you buy kenny uh phenom
you know
and why was it a good deal for the tax
site tom
well uh it the purchase price was 100
deductible so you offset all that other
income with the deduction for the
for the jet
and that eases travel so there's a nice
benefit there too
but imagine rich you sell a piece of
property or a business
and you you know you net three or four
million bucks and you have to pay tax on
that or you buy a jet you don't have to
pay tax on it
makes sense see guys this is how this is
how smart businessmen work and i know
that this
cas will
be
above the pay grade of a lot of people
that might be watching it right now and
one of the criticisms you know that i
hear a lot from
guys that watch my content when i say
things like you know it's never been
easier to make money and you know if you
can become an entrepreneur you should
get away from the job and not live just
over broke and you know create something
of some value oh rich you know you're
out of touch there's you know there's
only so much money out there and all the
rich people have it you'll never make it
and blah blah blah they've already lost
right but they lose touch of the fact
that you know the money supply has
doubled in the last like year
and and it's quite easy you know if you
do create value to you know create your
own business and do things like this and
then you end up you know in a position
where you have problems like okay i've
unloaded a piece of real estate and now
i have three or four million dollars
that could be a tax liability or i could
just buy a private jet
and solve my travel woes and not pay
those taxes sort of things but you know
they don't see it that way it's like you
know okay well what you know you you
create other solutions in lives and you
put money back in the system even even
if you're not paying taxes on it you now
have to employ people that maintain the
jet fuel it clean it you have a pilot
you have people that have to you know
deal with the food there's all kinds of
mechanisms that come into play like you
know robert you said that you employ a
lot of people so even if you may not pay
taxes on income that you earn that gets
transferred over to real estate you like
i know for uh tax liabilities here in
canada anyway even if i were to pay zero
in taxes i still have eht taxes i have
payroll deductions i've got cpp i've got
employment insurance
right
hst taxes
so yeah
that was that's why this is the second
book cashflow quadrant
these are mindsets right
and you if you don't change the mindset
nothing changes so this person always
say the same words i want a safe secure
job on a steady paycheck yeah
they can't unless they change that
nothing happens
and then this one is if you want it done
right do it by yourself these are
doctors and lawyers and all this
i always
laugh
i've met so many doctors who make a
million dollars a year but they're
paying 600 000 in taxes
i make a million dollars here i pay zero
taxes
who's smarter
here's the other thing rich you know
you know with with my real estate
holdings uh we pay
close to six million a year
in property tax
right which you can't get away from yeah
so which is tap so you know it's it's
i'm saying what i'm saying is but the
government at tom's point earlier is
giving me
a tax break for actually being in the
housing business because the government
is not in the housing business so they
rely on the private sector so they give
people incentives to build it to own it
you know some of them are affordability
tax credits and things like that and
they're needed you know those social
services are needed for people that need
a hand but what they do is they they
incentivize the industry and say listen
how can we get you guys to provide more
housing
and um
and and so we get the tax breaks for
doing all that work and putting things
you know because i put my balance sheet
up to you know to get a loan and to
build something or to buy something but
at the end of the day you know on a
three or four hundred unit building i'm
paying two to three hundred thousand a
year in property tax
to that municipality
and so you know those we are paying tax
plus we're playing paying sales tax
renters tax well plus your employees are
plus your employees are all paying tax
right yeah so
it's not like nobody it's not like
nobody pays tax that the reality is
that we're really all partners with the
government
right
we can be a silent partner which is the
e and the s side of the quadrant we're
just asylum partners we're paying our
tax going our way that's fine the
government's fine with that that you
know they know that they need tax mules
people who will uh pay that tax but then
there's the being the i side who are
actually active partners so like you
know if i invest with kenny i'm a silent
partner i'm not telling kenny what to do
and he's taking a share and i'm taking a
share and that's the way partnerships
work with the government same thing's
happening what what
happens with robert is the reason he's
paying no tax is because he's doing so
much of what the government wants done
that they're happy to have that
partnership because all the employees
are paying tax like kenny says there's
property tax their sales tax so they're
getting lots of money back they're just
not getting it from robert
so and rich what we're doing is we're
actually taking the the playbook from
the government regarding tax
and we're designing our investment
strategy around it
it's not the other way around it's you
know we're doing what they're asking us
to do
right can you
we're now i mean robert's got the rich
dad poor dad story um i think most
people that are watching probably heard
it but um
can you guys talk about that moment
where
you basically saw the code in the matrix
and you unplugged from the lies that
that that we're going to encourage you
to you know like i'm sure tom at some
point you probably work for an
accounting firm you know as a junior guy
and i'm sure ken you know at some point
you know before you started to acquire
real estate you're doing something you
know as a job sort of employee can you
guys kind of talk about those moments
and share those stories with people just
to give them some insight so they
understand that that
you know what you see and do right now
doesn't necessarily mean that that's
going to be what you're seeing and doing
when you get get on later on in life too
yeah so so i'll tell you about uh 26
years ago i started my first accounting
practice
and uh one of the first clients i had
had put away money in a pension plan
that's what most people do right put it
into an rsp some kind of pension plan
and he he retired the year he became my
client
and he started complaining to me goes
tom i don't understand i'm paying all
these taxes now that i'm with you i'm
paying all these taxes before that i
paid no taxes well because he just
postponed his taxes he hadn't eliminated
his taxes like robert does and ken does
he'd actually just postponed his taxes
and so now he's paying this huge amount
of taxes and you know when when i saw
that i'm just going wait a minute this
is a fool's errand you're just saying
i'm not going to eat my broccoli at the
beginning of the meal i'm going to eat
the end of the meal but it doesn't make
it taste any better right if you don't
like broccoli so the same thing is true
with the taxes you're actually in a
higher tax bracket when you retire
if you're making the same amount of
money
than you were when you were working
because you don't have any of the
deductions
so you're actually worth off in many
cases postponing that income and so what
what occurred to me is well what's
really going on with the tax law and and
frankly you know robert uh challenged me
to write this book tax free wealth and i
started looking at okay how does the tax
law really work and uh what really came
clear and i remember the moment when
robert and i were on and kenny and i
were on stage in las vegas actually at
the paris i don't know if you guys
remember that
and said look the tax law is a series
it's stimulus that's what it is it's
incentives and all of a sudden you know
blair singer turns to me goes what
he goes because once you realize that
you're just doing what the government
wants done
it changes everything it's that just
like you're saying rich it's how you
think about it because if you think that
it's my obligation to pay the most tax
possible
you
great do it
okay but if you realize that you can
actually contribute more to the
government
doing what they want you to do than just
paying taxes you know who's who's more
patriotic
yep
ken you got a story for us on that yeah
you bet so so mine's a little different
um i was uh i was a wrestler in high
school and i ended up getting
a scholarship and i used to wrestle all
up
actually simon fraser university alberta
all up in
in the provinces and also all over the
u.s
and i was going to business school and
so i i couldn't pay rent so i i took a
job at a an apartment building as a
manager and uh the owner came in
uh after a few months because it was a
mess when i took it over and i cleaned
it up you know it's pretty common sense
business i felt
and
he's like hey thanks for you know
turning this building around
and i handed him all the deposits you
know everything he went to the bank i'm
like man i'm on the wrong side of the
desk
so i got i got my real estate license
and i went to work for the company that
was managing that property
and they had a bunch of properties and i
ended up
working for them was my only job for
about eight years and uh i started to
learn how guys are putting partnerships
together syndications buying deals and
there were a lot of doctors and lawyers
and you know guy kind of hype i call
them high paid
you know commissioned people really um
and
you know and and uh so one day i just
said okay i've had enough i've had a
good learning curve i'm gonna start
going out and doing my own deals
and um i never looked back so that was
uh i'd call that in the mid to late 90s
and i've been doing it uh ever since
it's been buying i think so far
i've bought i'm not talking about
transaction through like as a gp close
to 3 billion since then uh personally
with my billion with a b
yeah
it's a lot
yeah yeah yeah
30 years worth you know
well
yeah i mean like a lot of people might
be watching this and saying oh you know
it's an overnight success where he got
lucky and you know you know good for him
with the jet sort of thing but
they don't see the 30 years of blood
sweat and tears that go into that right
yeah there's a couple there's a you know
i lost money uh you know there's there's
some mistakes in there for sure
uh you know as as there are
did you did you guys have any issues in
the 2008 financial crisis that that um
you know were problematic or did you
sail through it i did i i you know we
had learned luckily i had been in the
game for you know a bit by then and
i didn't have anything really heavily
leveraged and uh what happened in the
housing crash is they actually
when people fall out of single family
they go into rentals so i was in the
rental business so
that's actually we were on the right
side of that and we did very very
actually did very very well we actually
i'll tell you what i did is i went up to
canada
and we we put together a 100 million
dollar fund with the rrsp money and we
started buying in texas so i used
canadian money to buy
um all in the early 2000s and at the
time if you remember
your dollar was about the same yeah
because the u.s dollar was in trouble
so they invested in the into the our
texas deals and uh and then uh they did
really well but in addition to that our
dollar got stronger so so they had the
currency heads too so they they had a it
was a double whammy that that was
complete luck uh the currency part but
um
uh yeah so that's what we did uh you
know the us was on sale during that time
no one in the us was landing no you know
banks were taking property on and it was
a it was a show so
um you know so i'm like okay i gotta
figure this out so i'm like well either
asia europe or canada and uh you know i
had a lot of friends up in canada from
back in the day
so i went up there
good for you yeah yeah well well played
robert you're like the godfather of like
uh money and money and power and you
know pivoting and seeing this uh seeing
this reality can you talk to people a
little bit about you know
your your own unplugging i mean like you
wrote the book on it basically if you
guys haven't read rich dad poor dad get
the damn book it's on amazon read it and
read the follow-up stuff to it but can
you
shed a little bit of light on this one
for us too robert
well
these guys will you know i operate as a
team i was i'm a rugby player
and rugby players aren't the brightest
guys but they were they're running teams
and i was running a team
and so one of the first things uh rugby
players are submarine and marines
operated teams
but the most important person on my team
is my wife kim and these two guys will
tell you
she's the brains right
for sure
yeah i need to shoot the brain
she's who i call robert
[Laughter]
i didn't marry a rich woman but when i
met her
she had a job she was in advertising in
honolulu
and she would set up a little uh
network marketing businesses at a health
club
and she you know here's this gorgeous
woman
sitting there selling products and all
this stuff and said
you know she's got me she's hot she's
gorgeous she's sexy and she likes
business
so i i think that was one of the
smartest things i ever
i would agree
yeah
she freed me up
to go and do all the crazy stuff i was
doing because she could always pick up
the pieces right tom
that's right i could see in your um in
in some of your video content especially
when you're working with a group of
people that a uh
a team is very important with you was
that something that you learned in in
school or was that something that came
out of the military
that's military and rugby yeah
you